this week's videos are sponsored by expressvpn
more on them after the reaction people citizens of
the reject Nation it is time for Monarch episode
thress today John are you excited God yes oh man
I'm Ill with uh excitement that's insa we got to
watch the episode gu leave a like on this video
SM something I don't know m to the Subscribe
but can't think of anything clever thank you
to prep for helping us edit down these highlights
also thank you to everyone who's been joining us
at our patreon page for this show full l
through at and watch long where you SN it
with your own copy of Monarch for super
sexual reject cover several things over
there exclusively with highlights and watch
Longs included all righty guys let's get to
it what's it going to be wait a minute
we don't have a minute you don't want
to find out if your own father's alive or dead
that's your business but I do want to find out
we start or his Trail ended they searched
for his plane for weeks that's hundreds of
square miles of you know Alaska snow and
ice now this is a Milwaukee which means
an entirely different pruning process and
this is a Japanese man we just call him a
man here they're on to us get to the van I'll
drive you what interesting smash to Subs there
press the button button yes h Go Jack Burton
drive that truck watch out watch out watch
[Music] out oh boy oh that was a great shot
truly throwing down for some car stunts in this
show are you insane you never drove with your
grandmother hang on and he was in love with
her yeah it's a nice call back to episode two
oh my God you're destroying all of Japan yes
just drive it right through all of Tokyo bigger
Menace than the monsters themselves I'm a better
actor than my son wow what a transition shot
they do look a lot alike nice Saving Private
Shaw they've got to figure out a way where they
can interact with each other if you two want to
keep this our private little Monster hunting club
then fine we pull the request if you want make a
difference want to do some some serious science
and we need backing damn these Russel are good
actors what kind of difference are you going
to make welcome to Monarch General oh [__]
Chris hll who' have thought you'd partly escort
Duty into your first command these Eggheads are
already starting to grow on you sure it's a
bit like hurting cats sir if cats had Geer
counters and thought they were smarter than
you Egghead wants his bookie W Dr M William
Miranda congratulations on your promotion
General well thank you Miss of course and
it's doctor some respect on my degrees I believe
you have something to show us doctor oh my God
he just called her doctor without incident
oh he a tumor slowly growing in clearly got
an ulterior motive and is a villain tell me
this is some kind of fossil that would be a
reasonable guess but we took this impression
in a muddy field in Indonesia holy [__]
this is going to give me nightmares this and this
woman doctor nothing a lot of Firsts today we had
a way to lure it out of hiding all we need is 150
lb of uranium and let me explain that sir it's as
much as we dropped on Japan hey a creature like
this as big as this is an existential threat to
Global Security and only Americans can stop
it that's what we do can you imagine if this
came out before any the Godzilla movies I'd be
pretty excited say what it what is this building
too aside from the inevitable if it wasn't for
you neither of us would be here that is not a
theory that's a fact so you are saying that there
is a place for gun toting the Ander thals if we
hide who we are and what we're trying to do then
what's the point of doing it at all they're not
trying to hide it's about easing in yeah you got
to prepare people for like I'm a woman and and
I went to a lot of school I know medical thing
yeah and just general knowledge of Science and
the humanity nurse no no no uhuh not that kind of
doctor not that kind of doctor no the nurse not
a doctor yeah I am simply an expert in a field
of expertise Billy kept these journals scribbl
down every crazy thing he came across till his
pencils were nothing but Nubs I'd be so curious to
know how Wyatt and Kurt worked this role together
something thing in here Hoshi didn't want Monarch
to know about and my gut says we find it before
they do we find him but may built something to
read them but it's back at her place I actually I
digitized him already what all right Egghead need
you to look in there for anything about Alaska
why does he look so upset he just feels betrayed
when was Monarch founded uh late 40s thereabouts
who didn't that make you like 90 years old what
can I say good jeans no he's hiding something Je
spent out outside of normal SpaceTime did our dad
really work for them it is your family business
you got to warn people try to stop it hey that's
exactly what we were trying to do but you were
there you saw it you really think anything on
Earth could have stopped it then he threw his life
away for nothing oh they could have been mentally
[Music] prepared oh they're on a boat that makes
sense I was like why why would there be such a
gridlock right now bikini buttom what the hell who
oh no whoa I told you we couldn't trust that hey
hold on let me handle this let me just let me
handle this what brief did he give them I mean
they're treating like it's an enemy Must Destroy
This appears to be going in a direction we didn't
discuss we discussed you need a large quantity of
uranium not in bomb form sir should have been more
specific you could have told us that's not how top
secret nuclear tests work son God damn it asking
for as a chance to assess what we're dealing with
we don't even know what these things are they're
an existential threat to Global Security you did
say all the wrong things this is not what they
had in mind but it's become bigger than all of
us you ask for the support of the United States
Army this is it get used to it we know the the
weapons are kind of useless but can you really
blame the arm like I don't being told this giant
creatures here you I need to illuminated just lead
with your gun you don't need to stick your neck
off for us any longer this is my fault you cost
me my business and my home my life everything
I've built who I am damn but until we sort out
your mess and I get back what you cost me you
do not get to tell me what I need you're the
real monster man the Mello drama's the monster we
get one eager Bieber Border guard who finds these
ass and it's game over immediately so we need to
get rid of these just dump him over why do I have
to do everything you say and why are we going
to Korea my father disappeared in Alaska I out
of Japan didn't I under this ship no passport a
monarch in site that we know of you did a lot off
camera yes you did you two want to start calling
the shots you got every right so once we get there
where to Alaska like I said yeah man you don't
know what you're doing I want to call the shots
I just wanted to break you out yeah but I didn't
want your actual [Laughter] guidance okay where's
your friend just trust me okay I hope it's a K-pop
Cameo I think we're supposed to be in line number
two [__] did you want to sweet talk the lady at
the window I got my sister's uh adopted grandkids
with me right so we're we're on that ship and
I told them uh for safekeeping we got to put
everything in one backpack backpack right so
anyway look jeez I never been to North Korea
Swift no he was speaking in code yeah somebody
else heard well then you're even dumber than you
look hey my [Music] brother you
look younger every time you look
good you look younger oh ye a little faith come
on welcome to Japan ma'am I was supposed
to be moving my daughter into her college
dorm room this weekend but now my ex-husband is
celebrating this Milestone with her because Lee
Shaw has decided it's no longer Avail himself
of his generous retirement package I know so
much about her she's poised successful
businesswoman has a troubling marriage
and invested in her there no [__] get [__]
done that plane is being refueled and we'll be
ready to leave in 30 minutes you'll both Bey
on it Bill Rand is f 6-year-old field notes
and crackpot theories are not going to help us
avert another G yeah Lee Shaw seems to think
otherwise oh if you really believe they were
so important why not bring it to Dr sarawa
[Applause] or finally sh's in South Korea
official recognition AI plag him and the others
he's so excited you on that plane in 30 you get a
tactical team and get on Shaw's ass whatever you
need I need my partner yeah loyalty she's really
protecting him loyalty ready for Meed we're going
all the way to Alaska in that don't think of it
as old think of it as vintage think of it as a
sturdy piece of engineering from an older time
when [__] was made to last hopefully maybe who
knows they already figured out a
way how to lure seeing the creature
already right it's a theory it's a
strong Theory clearly they like the
radiation oo what do we got attention
attention sonar cont attention monster
we are the US government if you're
out there flap your wings one
time nicely done oh yeah goira it's like the
actual Godzilla movie no test they are trying
to kill it shim we call him go what the hell
does that thing need protection from us and
the [__] we do oh my God it is not bad wow
how have we never seen this thing before if
they go through with this how will we ever
know this is wrong stop the military Shaw
if we can't learn everything we can about the
enemy you wait to see what the enemy is going
to do you've already lost my bad wow nice
oh my God that water sale look at the Mist
on him that's a great shot let go a great shot
legitimate the hell did he needed to prove in
Kong Skull Island yeah seriously he's going to
wipe out this whole unit probably I don't know
9 8 oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy it's over
no dude it ain't going to do [__] don't
worry guys wow what a solid throwback to the
original
Godzilla's just going to be standing there with
his arms folded really what the [__] that's
Billy's handwriting there yeah these are geoc
coordinates from all over the world everything
on the list is checked off except for this one
when I put it into the map it's in Alaska if we
knew where your father's airplane was heading
when it disappeared I I could pinpoint this it
was flight 74 something filed a flat plan from
noome to Barrow numbers data time to Cowboy Up
Doo we got a new destination I got it Outback
Steakhouse he was headed to Barrow that's not
where he was going he was going for cigarettes
and never came back their first weapon was strong
enough to make Godzilla go away for a little bit
I gu I don't know unless Godzilla was just like ah
I'm not dealing with this just swam away General
called me in to discuss our funding so I gave him
a proposal string a monarch Outpost extra staff
monitoring equipment the works he rejected it
gave us more gave us a bigger budget yeah said we
didn't ask for enough they are giving us a blank
check to find out if there are more of those out
there oh that's a simple question what if the next
one doesn't pop up in the middle of the Pacific
what if it's near New York or Washington saying
that you want to go public with the details of
a classified hbomb explosion yes why not because
they electrocuted the rosenbergs this is a good
World building this is really a World building
yeah does the general need to know everything
I'm sorry are you suggesting that I lie to my
Superior officer no but a lie and a secret are two
different things what where he got it from this is
why I have affairs cuz a lie and a secret are two
different things thank you Lea use that one that
you will tell me everything that I need to know
are you okay with that are you I'm fine with it
it's my opinion matters n Monarch was supposed to
be something beautiful bright promising stri away
from Shaw where are we us we come to Papa soon
damn I don't know what I'm more afraid of though
we don't find dad or we do feels like a punch in
the gut either way and I don't know how many more
I can take let me tell you a secret not a lie you
don't appreciate your life so much until you're
afraid to lose it not so much when you see other
people lose theirs I saw many people die you get
out of the bay each morning you roll the dice
terrible things may happen true and never have
a chance to tell your papa to go screw himself
dude I like that guy I do wish I cared more about
the main two leads this everything else is really
engrossing interesting bucking why is he flying is
the fast pilot I know when you're flying by seat
of the pin put it right up here where I can see
it balance clever old school
leveler oh my God stop
[Music] Emma o boy this is going
to be rough guys hang on sh what's
that down there [__] hit my pants
no time to think about it here we
go hell of a job co- pilot you guys make a hell
of a team I mean that's his daughter it's true I
don't know whose daughter is who Kurt Russell
is the daughter oh no Kurt Russell's Got to
Be Blood related one of them yeah 747 what
got damn no did not have carousal behind the
wheel a that's not him it's not [Music] him seat
belts unbuckled maybe he got thrown free I'll be
monke his naked uncle has he got Camp do you
think anyone's there oh my God he's going to
see us to kids and be like oh sh [__] i'
never meant for you two to meet each other
this was the place that strategically you
should be least likely to find me in ever
I faked my death cuz I didn't want to deal
with this awkward finding out about each
other it's like he wanted to land
right here if everyone died in the
crash who set all his Gear Up Poltergeist
researchers I know that handwriting it's
Japanese me too whose handwriting
is it whoa it's their mom's he
survived a oh that's a nice moment yeah been
waiting to hug my hot sister this hold just
wait for the right [Music] excuse oh oh hatch
it's going to explode kill them all giant
[Music] grenade just made it look
like or something else came after
they landed and ripped it apart
some kind of M snow where you going
now nice that's terrifying oh is
it a Yeti PL you come quick move
wait how does he know it's
going to like awaken right
now all right all oh [__] wow look at that thing
damn come on my dude this seems like being in
the plane is the worst thing to be in
yeah wo nice like ice vacuum or is it
like should have got it in the plane what a
face it's all right old man shs been able to
figure his way out of every situation uhhuh
I'm sure he'll figure it out oh yeah very start of
the next episode he'll have like a special whistle
or something that like makes K incapacitated
for a minute jump back into action all right
all right damn you know with the dad in hiding
yes especially when he doesn't want to be like
caught by a monarch one of the best things he can
probably do is find ways of securing his location
and hiding keeping it secret but not lying about
it yeah totally totally but what would the best
way to be to to what would the best way be to
I'll show you right now I'll show you I'll show
you I'll show you naturally naturally to show
you yeah walk me through this yeah natural show
explain it to me I'll repeat all this you be the
camera and I'll be sure just look at this through
my eyes and naturally show you big thanks to
expressvpn for sponsoring this video a real
game changer I've been using for years that's
right years so whenever they want to work with
us it's an instant yes you've likely heard about
expressvpn for online privacy and security but
there's more to it than that however there was a
very real incident recently with Spectrum sheding
down my internet and contacting me due to a
suspecting hacking attempt and funny enough I
realized I hadn't actually activated my expressvpn
on my new laptop that I got a couple of months ago
so I was paying the consequences having faced a
serious hacking issue on YouTube a couple years
ago that made expressvpn my goto for both security
and freedom I mean it and yes what you've heard is
true believe me this channel knows you can use
Express PPN to watch movies and shows on Netflix
that are not available in your country this means
accessing a vast rate of content of over a 100
countries like a global Cinema ear finger tips
it's super easy open expressvpn switch locations
refresh the browser and there you have it whether
it's kramas on South Korean Netflix Hulu BBC I
player YouTube or more expressvpn has you covered
and it's incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming versatile to working
on not just computers but phones media consoles
Smart TVs and more this means you can enjoy
your favorite shows at any wear any screen
protect and elevate your internet experience
so if you want to get access to hundreds of
new shows use my link expressvpn.com reex and
you can get an extra 3 months of expressvpn
for free that's expressvpn.com reex so head
to expressvpn.com reject to learn more thank
you again wow that was informative that was very
inform very informative I have a little bit of a
headache but it's good John did you love it I I
liked this episode quite a bit I did you didn't
say you loved it and I really really really liked
it wow you're not quite at the love I'm I'm still
inching towards love but I really like it I like
that's my favorite one is yes out of the three
we've seen so far that's my favorite one sure
it's the most sort of like propulsive and it's
got a really kind of you know the I don't know
you're moving and you've got you know a couple
really good Kaiju touchstones on both timelines
I feel like we're actually unpacking new [__]
okay whereas before even if it is just sort
of flushing out and Monarch understanding how
Monarch came to be with its uh corruption is a
really cool angle to me of like oh this actually
really did start off as a uh wondrous Prospect
something truly just interested in learning about
these creatures yeah they're all Oppenheimer
they are like what horrible horrible door have
we open [__] now we have a clear B Innovation
yeah this is not what we meant by this yeah yeah
no that I I really like how it seems to Riff on
elements of of of history in the way how to my
understanding the original Godzilla was a metaphor
for threat of nuclear war am I correct about that
yeah all I think about our big monsters punching
each other the traumas not the deep [__] and
the fallouts ofar war blah blah blah real life
hisorical at put a guy in a costume and blow up
fake build smash the buildings with your funny
little screams rubber suits rubber suits yeah
yeah my bad what did I say oh I don't know
some [__] about history and Trauma and
you know you got very you really corrected me
on something like R rubber Greg Greg Greg rub
Greg rubber suits Greg rubber suits rubber suits
Greg guys guys in suits what the first movie is
a real metaphor about guys take off the suits
you'll be less angry um but no I mean like the
the way they were showing really showcasing
how the three of them you know young John
Goodman young Kurt Russell and and Grandma of Dr
and Dr Grandma who just gets to be the definitive
version of her character because we haven't seen
her in future do Dr woman uh Dr woman what say you
what are your feminine instincts telling you this
time every scene is it's a doctor a woman doctor
whoa what I hope they bring it every episode yeah
guys it's pet we're we're we're past World War II
now women have had jobs it's okay so the but that
like everything on the beach and everything that
was like hearkening back to like while while you
do get a little bit of like Nostalgia homage um
um um emotionality just that entire sequence yeah
I mean it's like it's always cool to see Godzilla
don't that's really cool and I love the visual
too with seeing through the um yeah through the
old camera through the old camera like wow that
feels so vintage to use their words uh but it
was a great aesthetic touch and the this show does
deal a lot with duplicitousness and dichotomy and
then seeing that within Monarch itself of like
they did really didn't want to attack Godzilla
they really wanted to understand and then you're
and then seeing I like I like when they're cutting
back and forth between I'm I'm I find myself now
super interested and compelled by the cutting back
and forth seeing how Shaw was the one who went to
the Army and approached them like he was just on
some escort Mission with this doctor and now he's
like open up the door for this secret Camp of of
government and you know they were like yeah you'll
get unlimited funding we're going to really help
you out and then he cut to the Future and he's
just like we got to keep him in prison and we're
taking control of the entire thing you know like
it's that it feels like it was really riffing on
something that feels real world yeah and and the
whole time I've been kind of watching the show
going like what the hell are they expanding upon
or showing me that is really all that different
than what we already know and they've really I
feel like this episode truly hit the mark and
maybe it hit hit it for people earlier already
for me this really hit the mark on Monarch being
something I really want to one pack yeah you
know that's probably my favorite aspect and
prior to this I didn't really get that sense I'm
like I always feel like monarch is always being
treated like they're kind of corrupt and then you
need them and yeah because who else is going to
deal with this who else is equipped yeah and
this one really um gave us a different angle
and there's mystery with like the first time they
actually discover goir which goes back to when uh
sir zawa does talk about that in the in the 2014
Godzilla movie you know so they we got that filled
in which is really cool to really get that entire
thing fleshed out um and should have said in the
middle of the reaction [__] I'm like well no I
know I just waited it's okay it's okay you got to
be you got to say everything but don't talk don't
talk too much don't talk too much but get all the
right things to say in the reaction so nothing
you know we should just start pausing wrecking the
watchalong experience and then just like making
sure we get each reference down before we move
on with the show so yeah bringing that in and and
then yeah uncovering under MOS as well yeah um my
main issue is I really just don't give a [__]
about the two kids like they're they're the way
they're portrayed is the most Baseline flat to me
it is is is so Baseline and like I I really like
the moment where they did hug yeah that was nice
they both finally have a reason to connect over
something you get a sense a little bit more sense
of depth of not willing to be vulnerable because
it's easier to kind of take out this anger and
pain on each other than it is to deal with the
fact that their dad is dead and did something
horrible so I get the subtext I do it's there
it's very it's very obvious but but the way it's
done the way they go about it is and it's and that
it's hampering of exposition it just kind of feels
repetitive a little monotonous uh I'm just not the
biggest fan of it and the performances are fine
they're fine performances they are I'm not going
to see and be like they're bad performances it but
they're not really doing something to they're not
strong enough though to elevate it Beyond its
flatly written material yeah if I was an actor
I would be hungry for more material to sink my
teeth into as those characters in particular
yeah yeah yeah cuz we see a lot of this these are
archetypical Beats and so especially when you're
in a position where yeah the script doesn't seem
seems least concerned about spending time writing
that story I I do feel for the actors in that
position because you're in a position where it's
going to kind of I don't know you're in danger of
Fading Into know a a long standing Trope rather
than your performance actually being accentuated
by the material the question about is the dad
alive and what's the dad really up to is just
Lightyear is more interesting than the actual kids
like the actual just question about it is so much
more interesting than than the kids even their
response too I'm just like I just want to know
what's going on with the dad and I'm not super
interested like and I think the show itself is
not that interested in them like the the writing
they put around the grandma who is is great Dr
woman she she's great her performance is great
I I really love her yeah um and then yeah with
the Shaws like so much of that is very compelling
um so for the most part I really it's it's all
that stuff where the writing of the characters
is the most intriguing it's them and and I like
ciry Clemens is I think K Clems is a really good
actress but even with her with the there there
kind of seems like I I feel like some something
in the writer's room I feel a note it might not
be true it just feels this way to me of we need
to provide something to make them more interest
we need like drama around them to make them more
interesting you could feel like them like throwing
in some note to try to include so it just reads
his kind of melod drama that bogs it down a little
bit then act actually feels like drama I find
really I personally find really interesting you
know yeah it feels like somebody mandated these
three characters in the show is like is including
them out of spite and is only concerned with doing
the bare minimum to have them there yeah which
is kind of funny to me because again this is a
show that is steeped in this lore and is building
this world out but that is you know having to rely
more on its human elements because they cannot
do a money sequence you know constantly um and
yeah it's it's funny to me because yeah I enjoyed
the immediacy of this episode and how much this is
moving things forward I'm much more compelled
by the characters combined with the story in
the past this episode was was fun for the present
sequences just because you know you're on a a ship
and then you're on a plane and we see a new Kaiju
and there's some fun to be had there although I
do and and not to spend too much time like you
know hypothesizing or rewriting but part of me
thinks that they could have accentuated this whole
plotline with the the two you know half siblings
a lot more if they had utilized a bit of that GTH
Edwards like soaking in the environment Vibe where
they're on a big you know World spanning Travel
basically and so I feel like we could have made
that feel like experiential in a way where without
even having to like write extra drama for them
we could just kind of be along for the journey
and bonding with them that way and have like a
few little moment like every time we come back to
those couple of characters it just feels the most
like oh I'm watching a show with like here's beats
that we got to do whereas I can get more lost in a
lot of the other stuff so it's like yeah I feel
for the actors cuz I I keep wanting them to you
know be able to I don't know like this got to be
a big opportunity for them and certainly you know
it's it's a good you know calling card but uh
yeah and the and the Bummer too is that they're
and I don't I really don't know what the general
consensus is on the on them as the main characters
yeah cuz you essentially got two sets of main
characters you got the people in the past you
got the people in the present yeah and then Shaw
is kind of like the connecting thread between the
two main characters two main sets of characters
right yeah and it's and in the present we got two
Asian leads uh which I think is really cool to get
especially when you have like the adaptation of
Godzilla Godzilla movies to get two Asian finally
to get like as like the two Asian leads it's not
like just Ken Watanabe as a co-star lead you know
yeah not not coming in to also fill something
of a Trope character yeah yeah I I think that's
that's really cool so I I I am wishing that they
they they were given something better here it's
weird that that um kento's mom is the still the
most distinct flavor to me of that whole story a
th% I'm right there with you cuz yeah she's she is
given these like regular human you know bit lines
but like everything about that feels like a person
and feels like they put a character on it whereas
whereas I feel like I'm I'm kind of just watching
like two protagonists capital P yeah yeah and I
feel like I don't really have fa Faith the show
is really going to change this op because this
has kind of been an ongoing opinion for us and
I feel like we can just be very repetitive here
so perhaps if it just carries on we'll just be
like they're still doing the thing we don't really
like whatever but if they but if we if they didn't
doing something that we really like about it then
all right [__] we'll talk about that because
this episode did ultimately provide me with a lot
of things I really did like aesthetically really
cool I do love the fact that they Embrace these
locations some stuff is a little bit silly when
you just throw your brain out the window and
you're just like oh [__] it I guess I got on
this fairy um Sur I was able to get us on like the
most inefficient form of travel well even though
we have a a truck here we we took that clearly
has a very identifiable license PL yeah yeah and
we've been under hyper surveillance up to this
point that I'm pretty sure has reached Beyond
The Compound we were only tractor they gave me was
apparently this this ankle bracelet not some weird
like track room my blood or some [__] yeah some
bug some bugo yeah as Hightech as this Monarch
organization is and as much surveillance as they
have on me it's okay I got it one step ahead the
government passport situation like all that stuff
this is this is really um spy heighten that is
filled in the blank by he's done a lot of [__]
in between that we just don't know about but it's
fun and Kurt and Kurt Russell is his Charisma
and charm and his the way he uses the way he
does his line reading the way he uses dialogue
really brings a lot off the there's a reason why
Kurt Russell is is the legend that he is cuz he's
no he's just known to like he's got a away with
dialogue that that makes you're like ah [__] it
I'm on board you Kurt Russell um so he and he's
such a delight and I really feel like he bring
he does bring a lot to this role and it is kind
of fun watching because I think Wyatt Russell's a
really good actor yeah he's one of the best like
nepotism you look like just like your dad kids a
good act and it's kind of like wow what a daunting
thing to be in the same show as your dad because
like your dad is a whole other caliber of talent
and you're like you're like really freaking good
like you're like Wyatt Russell is a great I still
remember watching that Black Mirror episode not
know oh yeah not knowing who that that was the son
of Kurt Russell and being like this is a great
actor who is this and then finding out that oh
my God that's Kurt Russell's son yeah and I had
no idea that was Kurt Russell so like I I formed
that opinion prior to knowing um but it is just
fun watching the roles just feel like one is just
so much significantly more charismatic but it's
it but at the same time like what Wyatt Russell
is doing that's why I would be curious to know
what the homework is for both of them because
where Shaw is at at the point in time where
Wyatt Russell's at that's what's required for
that performance yeah like like there is a little
bit more of a Carefree experience and same time
a lot more wounds have been inflicted on a guy
for where for where Kurt Russell's at where he's
just like [__] this I'm going to play by my own
rules a little bit you know whereas why Russell
was still up and coming and had to be obedient to
the Army at all costs and everything you know so
it is fun watching the dueling roles there of the
same character and um and uh I do like the kaju
stuff I like the themes of again of of of human
history that feels like allegorical to real life
to the point where oh when you're watching the
way this portrayed and then you're seeing the
traumatic events of what today is like with the
Godzilla incidents and the M from the 2014 movie
you're going oh maybe there was a path where they
may have been able to pre prevent some of this or
help prepare Humanity for it if they didn't just
make that one mistake of we got to just shoot this
thing yeah you know like was there a path where
they could have where we could have almost like
eased each other into coexistence yeah in some
greater way than just an immediate attack to to
leave that first impression yeah yeah so there's
a lot I really liked about this I'm really into
it when we're watching it yeah no I too and I'm
rooting for it to continue on and I'm like I'm
here for the mystery and I'm excited to find
stuff like yeah it's it has those those bits
that we have you know well Trot in in terms of how
it could be better and more gripping dramatically
speaking but shot great too was it oh shot yeah
yeah it no it totally is and and it's one of those
things where it does at least again when they
are going big scale like look really nice like
when you're going up the back plates on Godzilla
and that whole thing where it comes out of the
water and the Mist is coming out like it looks
really beautiful and yeah like I am enjoying the
spirit and and I think the way that they do the
the especially the way that they handle being in
the' 50s it feels kind of I'm able to just kind
of slip into it and not be I don't know that like
it's nicely heed to the point where it's not too
stylized and crazy it's not I don't know it just
feels kind of natural it doesn't feel as much like
oh this is a you know I don't know what I'm trying
to say like the sometimes you can feel the facade
especially when you're cutting back and forth and
especially on like a TV format like it doesn't
feel like they're stretched in any way bringing
that stuff to life and uh no it does doesn't yeah
and and and I think it's I think there's like the
way they work with the DP it it feels doesn't
feel like a shot like a show like there's a lot
of symmetry to Everything Everything feels very
thought out and composed and there it a lot of
times in I wouldn't the only time I've really said
that when it wasn't focused on Monsters was Gareth
Edwards 2014 movie yeah which I think is a very I
think it's a very underrated movie because it got
a lot of back for for the the way they chose to
capture Godzilla in the perspective and obscure
him a lot of the time and stuff so I understand
um but I think as time has gone on it's become
more appreciated it's personally my favorite of
the movies that have come out it's it's actually
my favorite I know it's not the one that we all
really want but I I find that the most effective
one it's the most well-rounded movie of all of
them it's definitely 2014 for me for my I I know
my rating easily 2014 Godzilla versus kong king
of the monsters Kong Skull Island um really yeah
a lot of people prefer Kong Skull Island over uh
king of the monsters and I don't I I prefer it's
definitely the bottom for me okay yeah my my my
ranking would probably be that it would be 2014
Kong Godzilla versus Kong Kong's Skull Island king
of the monsters yeah I'm not a big fan I've tried
Kong Kong always starts off like and then it just
really me every the last half I'm always like yeah
this is kind of this is really not the fun is
definitely wearing thin for me and I just get
annoyed it it can Plateau king of the monsters
is there there are aspects of that movie that
that are kind of like aggravating to me um but
but you know there's a lot of really beautiful
Monster stuff so they might even average out but
but yeah like but but my point that I was saying
was that clth Edwards I thought really shot every
moment of that with such composition and and scale
and and like you're there but be I'm saying even
when there wasn't a monster thing happening yeah
exactly no exactly whereas the other movies I sort
of feel like they Reserve that for the monster
stuff to sell it it doesn't really care about
doing that when you're in between scenes with
the hum like they're shot fine they're always shot
good but but but it's like okay they really that
that's when they really give a [__] and then
I would say this show matches that with Gareth
Edwards in at least in the intention of we really
care about every shot we're doing like every even
if it's just a talking scene which which is most
of this Mo they really give a [__] on how to
compose every frame yeah and I really appreciate
that uh especially for a television series yeah
where they that is a very filmmaker this still
feels like filmmaker driven which is kind of
strange because normally you're like you feel that
with the writing and not so much the directing and
I kind of have an inverse with this experience
yeah I feel like the directing is where the film
making shining and some of the writing is where I
feel a little bit pruner in in how they're doing
it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah there there are a lot
of there are a lot of perfunctory beats across a
lot of the characterizations and stuff like that
but I but yeah the to varying like to varying
degrees of appropriateness but yeah the the style
the mood the atmosphere is always on point and
it's like appropriately dreary when it needs to
be but then you'll have these nice contrasts of
like how beautiful it is when they're out on the
beach um and then yeah you're out in the ice and
whatnot and just like when you're looking up at
snow but then just like clouds and like you kind
of lose where the sky is like yeah there's a lot
of real Beauty and and things to Marvel at and uh
and yeah I appreciate so much about how they've
orchestrated this and I and I like that they're
giving us at least these like kooky little things
to wonder about like okay Kurt Russell how old is
he and is he like AG ing slowly is he regenerating
regenerating somehow is he is this going to be
like a Jurassic world character he's like a secret
clone or something like that which I don't know
how wacky they're going to ultimately go with
it but you know I like having little Mysteries
like that on the on the surface to at least
ponder about and uh and and yeah going back
like I did think that was a really nice moment
where the two kids are able to both identify
the handwriting it's like a real nice way to tie
that all together and you now we have you know
mo present and past Kaiju you know moments we got
this big ice dude with either the couldn't quite
tell if that was yeah like some kind of like the
force of the suction is so cold that it free froze
everything in the cabin of the plane I was sad I
like that guy I liked his uh his buddy from Korea
very obviously is going to die yeah yeah I mean
and that's what I mean by the writing there's a
lot of tropes and there's a lot of like this
is about what would happen you know in in the
writing and uh and yeah seems like right now it's
kind of always up to the actors to elevate it and
I think about it less in the the flashbacks cuz I
think the three of them just have more chemistry
I think that's what it is I think Kurt Russell
helps give chemistry with anybody he's directly
interacting with and the present Trio I don't
feel as much just like natural Chemistry Between
as like when you cut to three of them in the past
they have even when the writing could be better
and even when you're like oh I know exactly what's
going to happen the military's going to come in
they're going to be too gung-ho they're going to
lead completely ser and all that stuff you still
feel that sense of magic at the end when they kind
of strike that deal of like all right well you can
tell me everything I need to know you basically
can do your research and I'll act as a buffer
to help you get that done and deal with you know
the people upstairs who have clearly shown us how
they're going to handle our research or how our
our Endeavor here and I keep think at one part
of me in my rewrite brain I'm waiting to see how
the season plays out sure before I commit to this
thought is I don't think you need kiry Clemens I
think you could have translate transplanted a lot
of that to the sun it would have made him more
interesting if he himself had become some type
of like hacker person and he investigates it
himself but Greg and and I I think he has zero
chemistry with kiry Clemen there's none yeah and
I and I kind of I and they're supposed to be you
could make some weird [__] argument for him
and the sister being like they're distant and
St he's not allow no I honestly it kind of feels
to me like they went we have these two leads but
she's his half sister we cannot orchestrate a a
romance here so we need him to have an ex flame
so he can have a romance with a pretty lead who
we have sort of tacked on and I like that kind
of character that kiry Clemens is playing I like
the way she's playing it but I I don't disagree
in current form that there's no thought put in
her yeah she's here to be character and have
the you know info when it's needed basically she
so along for the adventure and I'm like but you
are the you you're so uninterested like yeah and
and again it's one of those things where I'm like
maybe if they they showed us that moment in the
previous episode where kentaro comes by and she
like blows him off and then she's like I'm working
on other things but she's clearly digitizing all
the Monarch stuff and it's like maybe just an
extra beat to show like what your obsession
with this is aside from just being annoyed that
he brought this to your door orud yeah give it
just give us like some secret fun [__] to unpack
even if it's just normal human Stakes by the end
that it reveals to be like give us something with
those characters to wonder about or to think of
their allegiances in relation to me melodrama or
character's arguing does not immediately equate
to strong conflict or compelling care it just
doesn't and and it's to me it just like it feels
like perfunctory melodrama and uh it does and
the way the brother and sister treat each other
is indicative of that because it's clear the main
beat that the two of them focus on is just like
our dad cheated and it's kind of like the only
piece of character history that informs most of
their interactions and then with kiry Clemens it's
just like oh we used to be together drama and uh I
yeah like it's yeah it's just one of those things
where you're sitting there going so boring you're
just like guys I and two I mean you never know but
like sitting here with everything as good as it is
now I'm everything else as sort of interesting
this so much of this for for as much as we've
had critique throughout this review this show is
like better and more engaging than I was expecting
like I'm having a lot of fun watching it and so
I expected it to be slightly better only because
the Rotten Tomato score was like through the roof
on it still is yeah it's so High yeah and and and
it's like I expected it to be see I yeah I didn't
see that until after we started watching the first
couple of episodes and I had a primer and so if
I had seen that I might be a a bit more disappo
I was damn this [__] just like almost at a
100 right now yeah and and so that yeah that
leads me to believe like oh it's got all the cool
pulp you want but also probably has like some at
least affecting drama and and he's like I I don't
really care about any of the drums like it's it
is about as boilerplate as you could get aside
from it being about a guy searching trying to
get his wife back or something you know like and
so that's I I I don't know how much to expect out
of that from the season going forward I certainly
hope that because this is all done I assume like
they're not it's not like Network TV where there's
a period of time where like you're shooting while
stuff's airing and you can actually adjust you
know uh so I don't know I just hope that that
maybe the writers feel emboldened upon the
back of this success in the future to yeah
write some actual like we've proven that we can
sit with some people in a Godzilla and it's fine
and now I think it'll only help you if you get
some actual interesting [__] those people to
do well guys uh got put work on the video right
now but what do you guys think about this episode
how are you feeling about the Monarch series thus
far leave your thoughts down below uh be sure to
subscribe leave a like and hey we will talk with
you all soon thank you for being [Music] here